today's topic like because it's so it
fascinates me when uh comedians because
we're so rough with each other right
when you go too far like when someone i
don't know there's always going to be
this unspoken thing between old
hollywood and young hollywood and that's
that's what's happening here and i'm old
hollywood yeah
you're a legend by the way you're not
any hollywood i'm your young
international you've never been
hollywood but that is hollywood no it's
young internet no but that's no
hollywood still exists no no one cares
about your friends like sandra bullock
no one cares about them i'm just saying
no one cares the [ __ ]
version uh-uh the thing where she wore
the blindfold in the canoe got 50
million views four years ago i'm just
saying bird box
bird box
the horror movie on netflix
he is right though
these new kids hollywood for them is
tick tock yes do you think what i'm
saying when you got charlie demilio
making 40 50 million a year that we know
of and he doesn't give a [ __ ] they don't
care what's happening with these actions
they don't care
they go on tick tock and those people
are the heroes they'll [ __ ] burn down
the whole building to see them people i
told you i wasn't saving with youtube i
was in south beach yeah i was in south
beach eating a salad and smoking and
shisha i was on the
the thing was on the side wall
and i turned around and i see who none
but tyson beckford gee
that the model the model tyson but he
looks the same he's 52 but he looks the
same right like [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
tyson medford that's because famous
people eat babies hearts so that that's
how they stay young yeah of course we
know that right damn right so he he's
sitting in the back of me right there at
the other table
but three people recognize me not him
yeah they don't know tyson beckford but
we know
it's tyson it's like
any you you tell any girl
from around our age they did oh yo you
saw him they they fall apart
[ __ ] don't care no they don't
care what about you guys in the comments
what do you guys think are you guys more
interested in internet personalities
whether it be on tick tock youtube
podcasts or hollywood actors who do you
think is the more relevant would you
care more about seeing sandra bullock or
maybe meeting your favorite radio host
like joe rogan or some other person i
think it depends what they do you know
what i mean like central bullet did the
thing four years ago right but if if
[ __ ] see silly and murphy
they're gonna be like oh [ __ ] silly
murphy a guy from peaky blinders the
main character from beacon bloggers how
do you think most people would care no
no it's possible unless it's like
zendaya but i feel like zendaya belongs
on tick tock too am i crazy for saying
that she got a tick tock head i am mad
at you for that am i crazy i ain't mad
at you for that
same thing for holland the boyfriend i
could be wrong what do you guys think
would you guys i thought people would
freak out more seeing one of the paul
brothers than they would seeing like
jaden smith or something you know what
i'm saying yeah
i don't know just my thoughts i know
everybody let's keep watching hey shout
out to tim dylan i actually i watching
this stuff this guy cracks me up and if
you don't know uh whitney cummings uh
she's uh a comedian a hack and um she's
a hack i'm just playing
i haven't watched her act right but i'm
prejudicial against white women so
that's just how i act
all right
is that the reason why i don't know
let's just uh
that's another topic for another day
i respect that we all know that you put
a lot into everything you do and i
respect you i try too hard with the
podcast no no no no no no you put a lot
into it and that's so much hey that's
okay i overthink it
yeah maybe i don't know i don't even
know if i'm good at podcasting that's
the other thing but
i think you are but
it's a very different thing like you
have celebrities on and you prepare and
you do all this stuff and i respect that
but it's like what we do it's just that
i mean secure tim i i don't i don't have
the white man thing of i'm just like who
wouldn't want to hear me talk for three
hours about anything like i don't i'm
not allowed to be boring i have to be
twice as good to get half as much
respect do you
do do you see that predator
right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah bro
bro bro bro stop talking all right you
know you hey hey i'm gonna give you that
double i'm gonna give you that dub
that's a double hey you was right i
don't have that my oh my god my
experience in the stand up comedy scene
all is that white women are the worst
okay like white female comics are just
the worst okay this is like so [ __ ]
annoying is unbelievable they want to
lecture you about every i got a white
woman what's your comment go up to me be
like um you know that bit that you do
about like spending some time in
ethiopia and in the civil war stuff i
feel like that's unacceptable i'm like
[ __ ] it's my experience you don't get
the [ __ ] up out of my face there was one
that that was cooling me about
she was schooling me about feminism and
talking to me like yeah well you're a
man you're a man your man i'm like [ __ ]
i'm a black man you're more pro no no no
no this is what i talk about but they
didn't like their cut when i said they
were in on the heist [ __ ] bro like like
women act like they're the most like
oppressed people calling me like i was
oppressing her and i'm like [ __ ] you're
a white woman
i'm a black you're a man
you know we had the
you're you're a woman and she's like and
she went to me you're a man i'm like
[ __ ] i'm a black man
let me just say why why yes
okay freckles and things let me let me
let me tell you this okay
i've had comedy clubs owner tell me i
don't have more than one black person on
a lineup because after that it gets to
get them okay
i don't make me when i do stand up
whether a comedy club lets me in whether
they accept me at open mic i don't get
pissy about my identity i don't care if
[ __ ] don't rock with me because
i'm like i don't i don't make that
crybaby excuse you don't want to rock me
i'll make my own shows i don't give a
[ __ ] okay i don't make the oppression
like the center of my whole existence
when i'm doing statement i don't care
that deeply
the amount that white women moan and
piss about complaining is unbelievable
you would think they were [ __ ] jews
in like in germany you know what i'm
saying like you would think it's world
war two for these like they're about to
go in the gas chamber tomorrow the way
these people no i'm not talking about
they talk like they have it the hardest
bro they get the most amount of
opportunities i i i cannot rock with
these ladies whatsoever on this topic
they annoy the [ __ ] out of me
they annoy the [ __ ] i be you see earlier
i was trying to be tame i'm a little
prejudiced so all this is behind that i
know i've heard so many wild comments
from why we've been in comedies wow oh
last conversation and then i said i'm a
black man she's like
oh yeah right yeah i was like shut the
[ __ ] up that's the only one she was
thinking but she didn't she should see
this
shut up
i don't have this thing where i'm a i'm
a i'm i'm a white man who can just talk
for hours and people just want to listen
have you not heard of the podcast called
caller daddy
isn't that a white woman just sitting
there talking about sex the whole time
and sucking dick
shout outs to her she got a big ass bag
from spotify at least she might be one
of the second or third highest paid yeah
okay she did her thing not for me don't
give a [ __ ] about the podcast okay but
get your back i don't think you're
talking about i'm not
you just might not be that talented or
you haven't put enough time stop moaning
just do it just do it god damn it i have
to be twice as good to get half as much
respect
um okay you disagree uh maybe well how
so
i don't know you have to be twice as
good i mean i just get half as much i
mean got you guys is that a line from
like a country song you guys can
definitely work in nine to five nobody
listening cause i'm a woman
is that true i'm just saying think about
i was thinking about this the other day
cause i was like how long am i gonna do
this podcast is there any proof in
history
that
people wanna listen to women talk did
not just stop me
stop
what every man has done that has a
podcast didn't ask that question they
just did it
stop asking so much questions just do it
go out there and do your [ __ ]
most podcasts most podcasts
are not successful
they're not
they're not
but they do it
just do you what are you saying question
do we not have oprah yes we do
do we not have the whole caller daddy
[ __ ] fiasco yes we do do we not have
a whole bunch of tv shows where people
watch brain dead women sitting around
the half circle talk about [ __ ] they
know [ __ ] all about the scientific yeah
okay there's plenty of tv shows that
women will indulge in that if they like
they'll enjoy all right so this whole
idea that people will not tune in to
watch women is [ __ ] [ __ ] daytime
tv was just like dominated by women for
so long okay is that some kind of like
issue where he's like well where are the
men where's the representation of men
doing daytime tv that was fine jesus
christ man
it's like these people just be looking
for [ __ ] like oh because we don't see
women everywhere it means that there's
some kind of oppression or maybe a lot
of y'all just not doing it so instead of
looking at how am i [ __ ] this up oh
no is that is that patriarchy yeah
so the second base biggest podcast karen
gilcariff georgia hand start my favorite
murder tooth women the eighth p highest
paid podcast is jillian penn state and
patrick hines so one female one male
okay and i'm pretty sure the caller
daddy just jumped up on this list as
well so there's a women on the top 10
list killing it you know what i'm saying
like what are we talking about yeah but
it's not as much women as men not
everything has to have equal
representation like i don't understand
that you know what i mean like
the market is what it is if people want
to watch more when they will but it's
not like these podcasts don't exist the
market is determined
well always their fault is it always the
people's fault has there ever been a
famous female radio host terry gross
like who's the who i mean i'm trying i'm
trying to think women aren't famous like
like for uh uh there are soothing voices
what about half the country that are
women that are not listening to those
women mm-hmm that's great i agree
women are also mad
women are also a manifestation of the
patriarchy yo you're you're you're yo yo
you're part of the problem you're stuck
in traffic right now if a podcast exists
and women choose not to listen to it as
well who's really causing the issue
patriarchy
man it's like breaths man
because because they they the way they
think and the way they you know they
just take everything and they steer the
boat women are gonna think that yo bruv
please
agree i mean i i
i like women i listen to i'm just saying
in the history of our entertainment yes
what who has been the female radio host
like cause you talk about um you know
howard stern and whose footsteps you're
following they're a big dj people like
angie martinez on hot 97
downtown julie brown yeah they're
kennedy yeah they're people but but
we're digging
yeah but who i i'm trying to assign
blame for that i can't assign blame i
just you're you're saying it whether we
we then now that we've established that
we have to assign blame yeah and we have
to go well what well who is it toxic
masculinity let's blame that is it that
it works well but then there's half the
country's women no i no agree that was i
was joking but
like when people like put out more like
do three shows a week like joe does i'm
like i feel like i'm good in small doses
right but that's your own internal thing
it might be my insecurity it's your
internal thing i mean if i had guests my
show would be destroyed how because by
them
i don't have an interest in talking to
hillary duff i'm sure she's a lovely
person i don't know why she doesn't have
an interest in talking to you great and
we're good we're good see this is the
thing with you you're like hollywood
doesn't care and i'm like we don't care
me and my friends don't care
it's just a reality we don't care
none of us want to walk into a writer's
room yeah with people that couldn't make
it as stand-ups yeah
go for it
oh my god
and i'll just say something real quick
you know sometimes we'll be ragging on
white women i know there's a bunch out
who watch us who are mad [ __ ] cool
it's fine
but
and stand up in a lot of the art scenes
that i've been in white women destroyed
everything
i don't know how they do that's why i'd
be saying shout out to whitewater i
don't know how y'all traumatized me this
much bro but in every scene i've been in
why we're screwing everything i'll be
just chilling sometimes and like you
mean [ __ ] chilling at a [ __ ] event
why would like did you hear that racist
comments like yo we just chilling why
are you bringing up racism to us like
why didn't you have to go out of your
way to bring this and make you just shut
up you know what i'm saying like
i don't know bro oh
that's going to just be making a thing
uh well there's no female podcasters
if you ignore the caller daddy stuff and
i'm sure there's more just i don't watch
them why aren't women watching these
podcasts are women also engaging in this
form of sexism if all these women are
engaging in sex and what do you want me
to do bro men and women are all engaged
in the same four sexes we're all hating
the same thing it's just you and your
friends who feel like there's a problem
just shut the [ __ ] up
it's it's
so so men engage in toxic masculinity
women is engaging in toxic masculinity
um women are victims of that toxic
masculinity and men are victim of toxic
masculinity let's let's call it
something else because the marketing of
this [ __ ] is not working okay let's just
[ __ ] call it something else because
that's not what it is it's not what it
is okay let's just stop i understand
where it's from the origins it's just
weird to me that we call it everything
toxic masculinity when women do it when
men do it it's toxic masculinity you
know what i mean but you know if you
take an example of racism when white
people do racism upon black people we
call it racism when black people
do racism against black people it's
self-hate
when the same group of black people do
racism but within a different color
grade of melanin we call that
classism or we call that colorism you
know i mean we all have the specific
word but when we talk about sexism
everything is toxic masculinity women do
it toxic masculinity men do it toxic
masculinity who suffers from it
women toxic masculinity if it's men
toxic mess come on now b the marketing
on that [ __ ] is off and we need to
revise that just saying okay oh no what
do you was thinking about this whole
thing no
i said what i said
it's just it's just funny that she was
talking about like
them in comedy
and it's a bit true sometimes yeah
there's a lot of there's a lot of
there's a lot of them that are really
cool that's the thing really cool
but the time that i'm there and i'm
being schooled and i'm like oh
girl no no
you're eating with them you you benefit
from that so
food killers mood killers anyways let us
know what you guys think in the comments
below or why women are the most
suppressed and if so who touched them
all right let us know in the comments
don't let us know